bonjour et bienvenue sur notre antenne
pour cette nouvelle édition de Parlement
Hebdo le meilleur de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire bonjour
Michael
actualité politique à la Une à l'UMP
l'heure est au règlement de compte une
dette de 74 millions et demi d'euros et
des nouvelles révélations de factures et
de notes de frais douteux le parti
cherche comment se sortir de la crise
avec ou sans Nicolas Sarkozy la réforme
territoriale adoptée à l'Assemblée les
députés de la commission des lois se
sont mis d'accord sur un nouveau
découpage le nombre des régions va
passer de 22 à 14 la carte de France
pourrait encore évoluer au cours des
débats ça sera la semaine prochaine et
puis adopter aussi le budget de la
Sécurité sociale sur fond de rectif de
contestation 33 députés frondeurs de la
majorité se sont abstenus sur ce projet
de loi rectificatif qui prévoit une
baisse de charge pour les entreprises
abstention aussi de très écologistes
mais pas de votre contre
et pour parler de toute cette actualité
nous vous accueillons bonjour Roger
caoutchi bonjour on va évidemment parler
de toute cette actualité de l'UMP vous
vous en doutez et bien évidemment et
d'abord on va peut-être s'intéresser un
tout petit peu à vous pourquoi un tout
petit peu c'est très vexant ah merci
puisque cette semaine nous sommes avec
Astrid de Vilaine bonjour Alors vous
prenez le bout du web et des réseaux
sociaux on va vous allez nous dire des
choses intéressantes sur Roger chaoti
mais d'abord une semaine de très
politique à l'UMP oui vous allez
beaucoup en parler de l'UMP pendant
cette émission et bien sûr le net aussi
cette semaine c'est une dominante
UMP on a vu tous les ténors du parti
défilé sur les réseaux sociaux à
commencer par Rachida Dati elle est mise
en cause par Le Canard Enchaîné pour des
factures téléphoniques à hauteur de
10000 euros par an payés par l'UMP selon
l'hebdomadaire et la réplique n'a pas
tardé de la part de l'ex garde des
sceaux qui a posté pas moins de 29
tweets entre mardi et mercredi sur cette
seule affaire elle commence par démentir
jamais aucun frais personnel n'a été
prise en large par l'UMP assure-t-elle
avant de viser directement François
Fillon qu'elle accuse d'être à l'origine
des fuites la théorie de la bonne
apparence dont se sert à l'agrement
François Fillon de notorise pas tout y
compris des méthodes de voyou et elle
conclut sa salve de tweet par celui-ci
assassin envers l'ancien Premier
ministre ce n'est pas de ma faute ni
celle de quiconque si François Fillon a
accepté d'être humilié pendant 5 ans par
Nicolas Sarkozy il a été relayé plus de
1200 fois
vraiment rigoler tout le monde à l'UMP
c'est le blues généralisé en tout cas de
ce qu'on peut voir sur le net beaucoup
font la comparaison avec le Brésil
éliminé de la Coupe du Monde par cette
butte à 1 c'est le cas de Nadine Morano
l'UMP c'est comme la déculotté du Brésil
sauf que c'est nous qui marquons contre
notre propre camp une gaulliste écoeurée
quant à Jean-Pierre Raffarin sur son
blog il parle d'une situation pas très
agréable et il ajoute heureusement que
petits enfants réussissent à faire de
belles percées dans cet emploi du temps
tissé serré elle en parlons de blogs
vous n'avez pas pu aller à Street sur le
blog de Roger caoutchou parce qu'il est
temps maintenant apparemment mais un
petit problème de serveur
je voudrais pas que ça vous demande mais
on a quand même réussi à dresser votre
irréputation à stream taper Roger
caoutchi dans Google et vous trouverez
non pas un blog puisqu'en effet il est
inaccessible en ce moment mais des
réseaux sociaux très bien entretenus
vous avez plus de 12000 followers sur
Twitter ce qui vous classe dixième des
sénateurs les plus suivis du réseau
social vous êtes derrière en revanche le
meilleur d'entre vous sur Twitter
Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui est suivi par
plus de 83000 personnes mais et là ça va
vous faire plaisir vous êtes devant
l'ancien président UMP du Sénat Gérard
Larcher
alors c'est vous qui gérez vos réseaux
sociaux vous Twitter vous-même vous
répondez même souvent aux commentaires
de votre page Facebook et votre photo de
profil est très appréciée par certains
journalistes qui trouvent que vous
ressemblez à si mes prendre au héros de
la série House of Cards le Sinik et
talentueux Franck Underwood je sais pas
si vous l'avez fait exprès vous nous
direz en tout cas pour votre présence et
votre communication en ligne on vous a
décerné la note de 7 sur 10
la photo quand même il devient président
du groupe de son parti au Sénat
américain et finit par devenir président
de la République c'est vous le Frank
Underwood français je suppose
dans cette photo ça nous rappelle rien
parce que
les ventes n'ont pas été considérables
mais c'était la photo de couverture du
livre que j'ai sorti en 2009 et qui
s'appelait mes quatre vérités et la
photo elle a été faite quand j'étais au
gouvernement dans les locaux du
ministère donc c'est la photo que j'ai
laissé par flemme à vrai dire mais à
l'époque je ne savais pas que j'allais
être concurrencé en direct du côté de la
Maison Blanche c'est vraiment ces
américains ils sont prêts à tout mais
non et puis je vous rassure si j'avais
le bonheur d'être le président du groupe
UMP MP au Sénat dans quelques mois ce
serait certainement pas avec des
méthodes de landerwood quelle méthode
alors
moi je suis ce qui nous ramène presque
vers le MP je suis plutôt un vrai
rassembleur quelqu'un qui déteste
détesté et qui déteste haïr et qui
trouve que la vie est suffisamment
pénible comme ça pour ne pas être ni
quelqu'un d'amer ni quelqu'un des gris
ni quelqu'un de haineux donc je n'ai de
haine à l'égard de personnes je préfère
trouver des voies de passage rassemblés
faire en sorte que les gens travaillent
ensemble
de mes ennemis amis parfois me le
reproche je ne suis pas un tueur moi je
fais toute ma vie publique plutôt sur
l'idée que on peut travailler ensemble
et pas sur l'idée que pour travailler il
faut descendre les autres non c'est pas
ma conception de l'engagement public à
toute l'actualité de la semaine merci
beaucoup Astrid et on quitte la toile
retour sur Terre avec un début de
semaine difficile pour le gouvernement à
la peine avec les syn dicats
la conférence sociale a bien eu lieu à
Paris mais quatre syndicats dont la CGT
et FO ont fait la politique de la chaise
vide échec ou dialogue de sourds retour
sur ces deux jours de réunion avec Rim
benhammer la troisième conférence
sociale a-t-elle été celle de trop avec
4 syndicats qui claquent la porte la
méthode chair à François Hollande est
mise à mal pourtant le gouvernement
préfère minimiser l'échec le ministre du
Travail va même jusqu'à ce féliciter
cette troisième conférence qui s'est
achevée hier a été un succès c'est un
temps fort du c'est un temps fort social
et je pense qu'il ne faut pas opposer
dialogue social et réformes syndical
Manuel Valls s'est montré ferme le
gouvernement ne change pas de ligne sa
feuille de route sociale pour l'année à
venir tient au une idée la relance de
l'économie trois priorités se dégagent
plus d'emplois plus de croissance et
plus de dialogue social parmi les
mesures annoncées une enveloppe de 200
millions d'euros pour atteindre
l'objectif de 500 000 apprentis d'ici à
2017 un nouveau geste fiscal en faveur
des classes moyennes et une négociation
sur les chômeurs de longue durée et sur
le dialogue social en entreprise des
annonces jugées satisfaisantes par le
patronat les syndicats réformistes qui
ont choisi de rester lors des
discussions note aussi des avancées mais
pour l'opposition une chose est sûre
cette conférence signe l'échec du
gouvernement Manuel Valls fête ses 100
jours en constatant l'échec du viral
social-démocrate et finalement les
Français sont en train de se rendre
compte que Manuel Valls a le même
problème que Jean-Marc Ayrault il
s'appelle François Hollande c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien que François Hollande
qui se disait le professionnel du
dialogue social va finir par dialoguer
tout seul à liser cette conférence
sociale est peut-être la dernière sous
cette forme contrairement aux autres
années le gouvernement n'a pas de
nouvelles éditions en 2015 alors Roger
carochi l'échec de cette conférence
sociale vous rigolez pas parce que dans
le fond sont les Français qui trinquent
mais enfin quand vous voyez le Premier
ministre qui dit trahi l'objectif
l'emploi ils se sont pris 500000
chômeurs de plus depuis François
Hollande avec un chiffre désastreux sur
le mai juin
d'abord celui de François Hollande qui
avait fait de dire une priorité globale
du gouvernement socialiste et de la
politique socialiste Manuel Valls a
succédé héros on peut pas dire que
jusqu'ici il y a des résultats par
rapport à une autre implication mais
malheureusement il a pas les mains
libres et on voit bien que c'est la même
chose qu'est-ce qui a changé en matière
de politique d'emploi rien qu'est-ce qui
a changé en matière de politique fiscale
on nous dit ah bah oui mais on va sortir
un million 800000 ménages qui étaient
rentré dans l'impôt social dans les
sorties de l'impôt mais en réalité rien
le rap la rapporteur socialiste de
de l'Assemblée nationale dit sur la
seule année 2013 les ménages et les
entreprises ont payé 29 milliards
d'impôts supplémentaires 29 milliards
d'impôts supplémentaires sur un an c'est
la rapporteur socialiste c'est pas nous
donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez je vous
dise plus de chômeurs plus d'impôts plus
de taxes moins de liberté et le
bavardage qu'ils appellent dialogue
social c'est du bavardage et revenir
c'est ça le dialogue social la SNCM
catastrophique où il est le dialogue
social et et des syndicats dans l'aérien
des grèves dans tous les transports des
grèves dans tous les domaines et on nous
dit dialogue social
des syndicats là qu'est-ce que vous
pensez
de MOI je pense que je suis pas là
mais moi je pense que ils se sont rendus
compte que c'est conférences ne
servaient à rien et qu'en réalité on les
utilise comme potiche venez à la
conférence pour légitimer la conférence
mais on n'a rien à vous annoncer on a
rien à vous donner et on a rien à
négocier mais enfin venez quand même
d'ailleurs regardez je l'aime beaucoup
François Rebsamen rien que la manière
dont il essaye de faire le bilan de
cette conférence on sent qu'il se dit
mais qu'est-ce que je peux bien inventer
pour avoir l'air d'avoir un rayon de
soleil sur cette océan de désastre voilà
la vérité le Premier ministre c'est là
aussi visiblement là-dedans quelque
chose qui ou sur lequel il peut gagner
en disant regardez-moi j'essaye de
bouger les syndicats sont bonsoir
et alors une fois qu'il a dit ça il fait
quoi pas facile
la seule politique stratégie de valse
c'est de dire j'essaye de faire des
réformes j'apparais comme un homme
d'autorité de dialogue et puis dans 6
mois dans un an je dis que rien ne
marche et que donc il faut que je m'en
aille pour pousser ma propre candidature
mais si vous dites
il vient d'arriver
qu'on sait partir au bout de trois mois
mais plus il reste plus il baisse
donc dans un an
de toute façon pourra rien faire d'autre
voilà on va passer au mardi cette fois
on va vraiment parler de l'UMP
l'UMP a l'heure des comptes le parti
s'est réuni au bureau politique suite à
la faire bigmalion l'audit a été remis
au 3 présidents par intérim et il a
constaté une dette de 74 millions
d'euros entre autres Germain
l'UMP n'est pas morte mais leur est au
régime sec
74,5 millions d'euros le montant de la
dette dévoilé hier lors du bureau
politique est réparti entre les prêts
bancaires pour 44 millions d'euros le
prêt immobilier pour le siège du parti
pour 28 millions d'euros sans oublier
les 2,4 millions d'euros à rembourser au
groupe UMP à l'Assemblée le parti garde
le soutien des banques jusqu'en 2017
alors pour la direction transitoire la
prochaine urgence c'est l'unité si le
vanp n'est pas capable de se rassembler
dans la volonté de travailler en commun
pour défendre les idées qui sont les
nôtres alors les questions financières
sont secondaires ce n'est pas ça qui
plombera le MP c'est pas ses finances
c'est son incapacité à se rassembler
autour d'objectifs communs et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons
vraiment et ça a été
des messages forts du bureau politique
toutes ces fuites organisées par je ne
sais qui s'arrêtent le plus vite
possible quand je dis ça il me faut une
bonne dose d'optimisme pour espérer être
entendu depuis ce week-end les fuites se
multiplient après le Journal du Dimanche
et les 8500 euros mensuels touchés par
Geoffroy Didier c'est le Canard Enchaîné
qui révèle des factures téléphoniques de
10000 euros par an payés par l'UMP à
Rachida Dati sur sa page Facebook
Jean-François Copé dénonce des souhaits
de vengeance et des rancœur personnels
qui semblent d’abord être à l'esprit de
certains membres de l'UMP mais à la
sortie du bureau politique aucun
commentaire sur La guerre des chiffres
et des factures le parti est tout à fait
en capacité de rembourser ses dettes et
te fait en capacité d'avoir une action
militante et sera évidemment présent à
partir de mon augmente notamment nos
recettes on fera tout pour gagner dans
les meilleures conditions possibles de
toute façon il faut bien faire face aux
difficultés qui sont les nôtres et en y
arrivera le parti doit désormais baisser
ses dépenses de fonctionnement et
augmenter le nombre des 143 000
adhérents à jour de cotisations pour
trouver de nouvelles ressources
prochaine échéance l'élection du nouveau
président de l'UMP et l'organisation
d'un congrès le 7 décembre alors les
contes et les règlements de comptes on
en parle tout de suite avec le zoom de
Denis Jean Bart
bonjour Denis bonjour Katia merci d'être
avec nous pour nous parler de tout ça
autant d'affaires révélées et autant de
dettes ça fait beaucoup est-ce que l'UMP
est toujours viable qui peut encore
croire dans ces conditions à l'avenir de
l'UMP écoutez malgré l'image qu'on vient
de voir de ce trium vira plus monsieur
Châtel qui semblait assister à l'Inter
manque de lui devant le catafalc je ne
crois absolument pas la disparition de
de l'UMP d'abord je pense que le la
question financière peut-être surmontée
reste quand même des moyens non
négligeables et puis il y a des actifs
ça c'est la première question et puis
politiquement je crois que même si on
assiste à une guerre des Astrides il y
aura à la fin un président et une
organisation qui se remettra en marche
sera sans doute des gens qui seront
marginalisés des victimes on verra
comment se déroule ce combat tout à fait
suspendu à la décision de Nicolas
Sarkozy de se présenter ou pas à la à la
présidente et puis je crois moi que un
parti politique c'est pas simplement la
super structure c'est aussi tout le
réseau national il faut pas oublier que
nous avons eu des élections municipales
historiques c'est-à-dire avec un nombre
de villes conquis par le
l'UMP et de nouveaux acteurs politiques
ce qui m'a frappé dans cette élection
c'est qu'il y a une nouvelle génération
qui est arrivée et les villes c'est des
moyens aussi faut pas se cacher derrière
son petit doigt c'est des moyens donnés
et c'est une base politique très forte
pour la reconquête et donc dès lors que
les problèmes financiers les problèmes
de dirigeants et de projets politiques
seront réglés je pense que du même l'UMP
repartira de l'avant donc ça fait
plaisir
comme c'est la mienne d'analyse tout va
bien alors là je suis merci beaucoup
en tout genre on passe on met de côté
l'aspect financier mais visiblement là
on est d'accord tout le monde est
d'accord règlement de compte en tout
genre est-ce que c'est l'échec du trium
vera comme on les a appelé non c'est le
fait que comme toujours quand vous avez
grave difficulté là c'était à la fois la
dette la faire bigmalion la démission de
Copé c'est-à-dire vous avez à la fois
problème financier problème de
transparence problème de pouvoir
politique quand vous avez ça il y a
forcément ou des choses qui sortent ou
des gens qui exaltent leur haine ou leur
mécontentement par rapport à
sortir tout ça
non le MP a décidé à la demandeur de je
crois de Luc Châtel Jean perraffin et
elle demande de Xavier Bertrand le père
décidait de faire quelques
investigations internes pour savoir d'où
viennent si vous ne soyez pas d'où
viennent des flèches mais on va voir
mais sincèrement moi je vais vous dire
bienvenue
vous savez bien que la politique certes
c'est des idées mais ces idées sont
toujours portées par des hommes et la
politique est aussi un combat entre des
hommes et c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à l'UMP le vrai sujet c'est
l'élan c'est à dire qu'à mon avis
lorsqu'on va rentrer pour de bons dans
la campagne pour l'élection à la
présidence de l'UMP c'est-à-dire à la
fin du mois
d'août donc lorsque l'idée
sur plein de choses mais pas tout de
suite mais alors voilà donc à la fin du
mois d'août on sera globalement qui est
candidat pour le moyen il y en a deux
qui sont déclarés il y en aura
probablement deux ou trois autres bon à
ce moment-là les rivalités les pics les
tweets les
disparaîtront devant la formation de
nouveaux camps autour d'un projet parce
que ce qu'il faut c'est que ce soit
Bruno Le Maire que ce soit Hervé Marie
ton que ce soit Nicolas Sarkozy revenait
que ce soit d'autre s'ils sont candidats
non seulement ils disent j'ai une écurie
mais ils disent un projet parce que ce
qu'attendent les adhérents c'est sur
quel fondement idéologique on veut aller
vers la présidence
est capable
en l'occurrence de faire vivre des
courants différents comme le Parti
socialiste a su le faire tout en
traversant lui aussi des périodes très
difficiles fait référence notamment au
congrès de Rennes moi je crois non moi
je parle il faudra qu'on a une réflexion
moi j'étais très attaché au fait de sur
la fondation de l'UMP autour d'Alain
Juppé et d'autres de dire les gaullistes
les libéraux les démocrates chrétiens
les centres et des radicaux bon on a
voulu faire une bataille de motion je le
dis d'autant plus que moi j'ai aussi
participé à la bataille avec une motion
Golie on n'a pas vraiment d'ailleurs
fait campagne nous puisqu'on était plus
sur la présidence mais là c'est trop je
trouve pour une formation politique
comme la nôtre rassemblant des
gaullistes des libéraux des centristes
faisant en sorte que tout le monde ait
envie de vivre ensemble après ce qu'il
faut à l'intérieur des mouvances
d'émotions des tendances non il faut
beaucoup de liberté il faut que des gens
centrisent avoir une option un peu
différente sur l'Europe que les
gaullistes il faut etc est-ce qu'il faut
sectoriser tout ça
et même Nicolas Sarkozy en a parlé il
faut tout changer dans le Figaro
Magazine il y a peu de temps faut tout
changer faut changer le nom de l'UMP il
faut toujours balayer moi je pense qu'à
un moment vous savez moi j'ai adhéré à
la formation gaulliste ça s'appelait
l'idée c'est devenu le RPR et puis on
s'est fondu dans le MP moi je pense que
l'UMP après l'élection à la présidence
de l'UMP il faudra que le nouveau
président réfléchisse je suis moi
favorable au fait de changer de changer
pas juste changer le nom parce que je
disais juste pour changer le nom mais de
refaire une fondation c'est-à-dire de
dire voilà le projet sur lequel le
nouveau président serait élu autour de
ce projet on peut agréger plus de monde
que les adhérents actuels de l'UMP
créons autre chose qui s'appellera
différemment et qui surtout dira on
s'ouvre à des gens qui jusqu'ici soit
ont été créés par le MP sont partis soit
n'ont jamais adhérer à rien comme on
l'avait fait de la création
que vous défendez aussi une primaire
est-ce que ça peut se conjuguer
vous savez on m'a beaucoup reproché on a
dit que j'étais l'un des rares Sarkozy
de favorable la primaire j'affirme qu'il
faut l'imprimer y compris pour Nicolas
Sarkozy président
parce que il nous faut un scrutin ouvert
à tous de manière à avoir un seul
candidat pour les potentiel non à tous
et connaît un bon candidat pour être sûr
d'être au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle de 2017
on continue on va passer à un autre truc
qui a été examiné à la loupe cette
semaine par le gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le budget
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale vous
savez on a beaucoup parlé de ces
frondeurs retour sur la séance avec
Jean-Baptiste Daoulas
pour
272 contre 234 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté aucun socialiste n'a voté contre
mais 33 frondeurs du PS se sont abstenus
sur le budget rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale et même 35 en comptant
les deux députés socialistes qui ont
voté pour par erreur un message adressé
à François Hollande et au gouvernement
c'est à la fois un droit d'alerte bien
sûr mais c'est aussi un vote
d'avertissement on ne peut pas continuer
comme ça il faut retrouver à la fois le
dialogue à l'Assemblée pour ressouder la
majorité ça c'est la responsabilité du
Premier ministre mais aussi les voies du
dialogue social et c'est la
responsabilité là de l'exécutif
également 35 abstentions dans le groupe
socialiste C6 de moins que pour le pacte
de stabilité en avril de quoi espérer un
essoufflement de la Fronde pour le
gouvernement bien sûr qu'il y a encore
des gens à convaincre mais je constate
que au fur et à mesure étape étape nous
sommes plus nombreux plus forts plus
déterminés avancé sur la voie des
réformes mais les tensions restent vives
dans le groupe socialiste jusqu'au bout
une poignée de frondeurs ont menacé de
voter contre un avertissement que les
patrons de la majorité n'ont pas du tout
apprécié oui je leur dis que c'est vrai
c'est un avertissement il convient de ne
pas commencer à la rentrée les frondeurs
tentés par un vote ont été menacés
d'exclusion un ultimatum qui pourrait
servir à nouveau lors du marathon
budgétaire de l'automne
alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit de ses
frondeurs qu'ils étaient des couteaux
sans lames qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
toujours difficile dans un groupe ou un
parti politique de ne pas voter pour le
gouvernement quand il est issu de vos
rangs on l'a connu
mais ça en dit long je veux dire 33
socialistes très écolos qui ne votent
pas finalement alors ils sont pas allés
jusqu'à voter contre parce qu'ils
savaient que dans ces conditions c'était
quand même très très compliqué de faire
chuter mais je pense que depuis
plusieurs semaines vous savez au Sénat
par exemple les sociétés vous disent bah
ça y est Hollande a réussi à éradiquer
le socialisme municipal elle nous fait
perdre toutes nos villes il a quasi
éradiquer les députés européens
socialistes s'il continuent à ce rythme
on n'aura plus rien donc il y a une
ambiance à l'UMP je dis pas que ça va
bien mais nous au moins on gagne les
élections municipales et on a encore une
capacité à gagner la suite
eux se disent
l'actuel pouvoir nous conduit au
désastre donc
ils savent plus trop bien ce qu'il doit
faire leurs électeurs au moins de parler
de franchise vous le reconnaissez ça des
choses ils disent que leur disent leurs
électeurs
seul nous est arrivé d'avoir des députés
ou des parlementaires de manière
générale qui ne votent pas en même temps
que le gouvernement
presque plus au Sénat où il y a eu plus
de liberté toujours qu'à l'Assemblée moi
je suis pas caporaliste je pense que
dans un groupe politique les élus il
faut les respecter il faut les écouter
et il faut travailler du budget cette
fois sur le fondateur budgétaire qui se
profile là pour la rentrée avec autant
de dettes de déficit budgétaire vous
même vous faites comment vous faites
quel arbitrage pour pour que tout soit
sur les rails déjà on a dit alors on se
bat est-ce que c'est 50 milliards 60
milliards très bien mais de réduction de
la dépense publique mais les chiffres
astronomiques bien sûr ce sont des
chiffres astronomiques enfin le
gouvernement il a pris la position la
plus facile c'est à dire que pour le
moment le seul chiffre qui lui est quasi
intangible les 11 milliards qui va pas
donner aux collectivités territoriales
parce que c'est le plus facile dans tous
les ministres de la Défense
parce que franchement on peut pas dire
on est autre Tchad on est au Mali il
faut intervenir on a des éléments Côte
d'Ivoire il y a les situations qui sont
celles du Proche et Moyen-Orient et
réduire et continuer de réduire les
crédits de la dépense naturelle mais
bien sûr parce que ça sert d'avoir fait
un livre blanc sur la défense d'avoir
une loi de programmation militaire pour
dire oui c'est une faute lourde par
rapport à ce que nous sommes et au rôle
de la France nous avons déjà une image
catastrophique dans le monde du fait de
notre politique économique et sociale
à la défense moi je pense que la défense
la sécurité l'emploi doivent être
préservés pour le reste est-ce qu'il
faut comme le fait de gouvernement
confirmer qu'il veut faire ses 60000
postes dans l'éducation sincèrement
c'est pas crédible de la même manière on
ne fait pas suffisamment d'économies sur
un certain nombre de ministère et sur
des dépenses qui n'ont pas de sens
parce que la semaine passe vite on est
déjà à mercredi et l'assemblée qui
s'empare de la réforme territoriale
on va parler évidemment de cette carte
des régions le projet de loi a été
rejeté au Sénat en première lecture il a
été examiné donc en commission à
l'Assemblée résultat une carte modifiée
et un nouveau droit pour les
départements celui de choisir sa région
Jean-Baptiste Daoulas
c'est une carte légèrement modifiée que
la commission des lois a adopté cette
semaine le Limousin fusionnerait
désormais avec l'Aquitaine l'évolution
que j'ai à laquelle j'ai procédé sur la
carte et ma foi assez simple et assez
clair et je pense que le débat doit
maintenant avoir lieu j'entends en tout
cas dans ses propos que ce n'est pas
encore la carte idéale ni forcément
définitive puisque nous sommes au début
même de nos débats notre assemblée ce
doit de se saisir de la carte ça ça va
de soi avec ce point de vue je partage
la vie qui a été exprimée tout à l'heure
mais qu'il faut se saisir la carte pour
la réviser très sérieusement
l'opposition veut une refonte complète
de la carte les socialistes veulent
simplement la faire évoluer quoi qu'il
en soit la carte validé cette semaine
pourrait encore être largement modifiée
dans l'hémicycle autre débat le droit
d'option des départements c'est-à-dire
la possibilité pour un département de
quitter une région pour en rejoindre une
autre entre 2016 et 2020 le projet de
loi initial prévoyait des référendum
locaux pour simplifier la procédure le
rapporteur à proposer leur suppression
et l'idée
en plus de retirer les référendum locaux
c'est tout de même que chacune des
régions est le département concerné
puissent donner leur avis le texte
prévoit un vote aux 3/5 du conseil
général du département concerné mais
aussi du conseil régional des régions
d'arrivée et de départ si on demande
aussi
l'accord de la région de départ si on
peut dire on sait très bien que cela va
entraîner des débats qui vont donner en
quelque sorte un droit de veto dans ces
conditions il sera toujours très
compliqué pour un département de changer
de région alors une réaction sur ce
droit d'option il semble difficile à
être mis en oeuvre si on entend ce que
dit voilà est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre est-ce que c'est un droit
politique ou un droit baronique
c'est logique et normal de laisser au
département une capacité de décider la
seule réalité c'est que quand on veut
changer une carte territorielle de la
France pour les 50 ans qui viennent il
faudrait déjà dire quelles sont les
compétences économiques qu'elles sont
les compétences tout court que l'on va
donner aux régions le vrai le vrai mais
non elle est très mauvaise on fait deux
textes d'abord on découpe et après on
vous dit quels sont les pouvoirs qu'on
donne aux uns aux autres et on dit on
veut des grandes régions mais on veut
faire disparaître les départements c'est
absurde où on dit on laisse les
départements et on fait de grandes
régions où on dit on ne fait disparaître
les départements et alors il faut au
contraire de petites régions pour qu'il
y a un pouvoir de proximité donc là
c'est absurde sur la réflexion c'est
absurde sur l'ordre des deux textes
puisqu'il y a un texte qui va venir mais
après et là je leur souhaite du bonheur
dans l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que vous verrez que les députés
languedocien y compris de gauche vont
dire même en rêve jamais on ira avec
Midi-Pyrénées vous verrez que les
députés bretons même de gauche vont dire
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
avec Pays de la Loire machin vous verrez
que les députés du Limousin vont dire
mais pourquoi on nous met d'autorité
avec
machin enfin mais c'est comme ça parce
que si vous ne dites rien toucher mais
non c'est pas qu'on peut rien toucher
c'est que on aurait dit c'est ce que
disait Jean-Pierre Raffin est-ce que dit
d'ailleurs genre là chez les deux vous
voyez comme quoi disait mais pourquoi on
nous laisse pas 6 mois on vous on vous
dites ce que seront les pouvoirs des
départements les pouvoirs des régions et
à partir de là si on nous dit par
exemple les régions les transports en le
développement économique moi je vous dis
voilà telle région a les mêmes problèmes
les mêmes intérêts en matière de
transport de développement économique
d'emploi c'est le même bassin d'emploi
regroupons les mais on va le faire
on va le faire au Sénat à la deuxième
lecture on a décidé avec Jean-Pierre
avec Gérard avec Jean-Claude avec tous
ceux qui sont des gens de bien et qui
savent travailler on a décidé de dire
nous pendant les mois qui viennent on va
travailler sur les pouvoirs les
compétences les moyens et à partir de là
on présente par exemple le rattachement
de l'Oise à la région c'est votre on me
demande déjà si on veut leur et Loire ou
le Loiret je suis pour une grande région
Bassin parisien pourquoi pas mais en
même temps je ne suis pas pour casser
les régions des voisins ça n'a pas de
sens et tout ça ça doit être discuté
négocié c'est pas un tour de passe-passe
et puisqu'on parle du scénario on va
parler transparence le Sénat qui fait un
petit pas supplémentaire va transparence
notamment sur les groupes politiques
après les soupçons de détournement de
fonds du groupe UMP de bureau décida a
décidé de détournement de fonds
le contrôle des dotations qui ont été
faites au groupe les explications de
Sophie normand
la décision a été prise à l'unanimité
par le Bureau du Sénat à partir de 2015
les groupes politiques de la Haute
Assemblée devront faire certifier leur
compte par un commissaire aux comptes
c'est tout simplement avoir une
comptabilité à jour et avoir un plan
comptable réel et
les aides accordées ne peuvent pas
servir à autre chose qu'à l'activité du
groupe nous avons jugé liquide de
prendre cette décision c'est pour nous
bien sûr évidemment c'est une fois
certifié les contes devront être remis
au président du scénario questeur tous
les 31 mars sans quoi les dotations
seront suspendues à droite comme à
gauche cette décision est saluée je
pense que c'est une garantie
supplémentaire qui est dans le processus
de clarification qui est engagé au Sénat
comme ailleurs et que c'était une
décision de progrès il faut que tout le
monde soit au clair non pas pour en
rajouter pour montrer du doigt pour une
suspicion mais pour dire il n'y a pas de
problème cette décision s'inscrit dans
une volonté de transparence de la vie
politique et alors qu'une enquête a été
ouverte sur des soupçons de détournement
de dotation versé par le Sénat au groupe
UMP comme le dissophie Normand il y a eu
des soupçons une enquête est en cours on
va voir ce que dit l'enquête j'ai pas
plus élément que ça mais ce qui
reprochait donc ce qui sont directement
concernés en répondant c'est de dire
quand on a créé le groupe UMP on a
regroupé des centrises délibéraux
d'égoïste etc et il y a eu la mise en
place de famille de sous famille si je
peux dire libéral centriste on dit le
groupe UMP pour le fonctionnement de ces
sous-familles à verser une partie de la
subvention alors est-ce que c'est
illégal je n'en sais rien à mon sens pas
vraiment mais on va voir ce que durant
les juge
en attendant ce qui est clair ce que
nous nous avons parfaitement accepté
l'idée de faire certifier les comptes
moi je trouve même d'ailleurs que la
décision du Bureau du Sénat elle est
tardive puisque ils disent c'est à
partir de 2015 c'est à dire qu'en
réalité la première certification sera
en mars 2016 moi j'aurais dit on peut le
faire du mars
il y a plus de ce il y a plus de ce
genre de choses vous dites transparence
totale
il faut des commissaires aux comptes il
y a déjà au groupe UMP du Sénas qui
n'existait pas celui de l'Assemblée un
trésorier moi je trouve que il faut
naturellement et puis il faut parce que
je vais vous dire la vérité et je le dis
à tous mes collègues du Sénat
régulièrement quand je leur parle le
vrai élément c'est qu'il faut en même
temps protéger les sénateurs moi je ne
supporte pas et si j'étais un jour
président de groupe je ne supporterai
pas comme étant en cause l'honorabilité
et la transparence des éléments de notre
groupe donc il faut de la transparence
il faut la vérité non si il faut tout
dire tout publier de manière à ce que il
y ait pas le moindre doute sur
laurabilité l'honneur
politique il faut la laisser les
sénateurs sont là comme les députés pour
être libre dans leur action politique
s'il y avait un contrôle ça deviendrait
compliqué parce qu'on pourrait dire le
jour où vous avez un pouvoir un peu plus
un peu moins démocratique alors c'est
fini il y a plus de liberté du tout mais
sur le problème financier vous savez le
groupe UMP du Sénat n'avait pas accepté
de prêter à l'UMP ce qu'a fait de
manière légale d'ailleurs je dis pas le
contraire le groupe MP de l'Assemblée
mais le groupe
Godin avait dit non voilà et et sur le
reste moi qui ai des comptes certifiés
transparent publié ça me va bien
d'ailleurs ça pousse quand même cette
vraie question parce qu'on l'a vu cette
semaine à l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'utilisation de l'argent qui est fait
par par les députés ou par les sénateurs
sur l'embauche notamment au niveau de la
famille est-ce que ça veut dire que les
groupes politiques mais ce que ça veut
dire quand même plus largement que les
groupes politiques peuvent utiliser
l'argent du contribuable comme ils le
souhaitent non mais moi je passe pas
comme ça d'ailleurs dans la décision du
Bureau du Sénat très clairement dit la
dotation elle est faite pour les emplois
dans le cadre du fonctionnement du
groupe et pour les actions du groupe
dans le bar rien d'autre ça c'est clair
mais en revanche par exemple soit
l'assemblée au Sénat on donne tous les
mois une cotisation des élus à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat les députés
et les sénateurs UMP mais pareil dans
les autres groupes vous donnez à votre
groupe une cotisation là c'est bien sûr
et là
au groupe
UMP du Sénat en réalité alors c'est un
système un peu compliqué mais enfin en
réalité on est à on est aux alentours de
700 euros et à l'Assemblée ils sont un
peu moins mais parce qu'ils ont des
modes de d'activité puissions plus
nombreux mais le problème n'est même pas
là ensuite ça ça veut dire que sur cet
argent là le groupe doit avoir une
action politique plus libre c'est pas
une dotation de l'État là c'est une
cotisation des élus donc moi je serais
même pour qu'à terme on dise à la limite
chaque groupe pour avoir deux comptes le
compte de la dotation de l'Assemblée ou
du Sénat strictement encadré publié etc
et le compte sur les les cotisations
d'élus ou vous devez rendre compte à vos
élus vous pouvez publier mais où là
l'activité est plus libre parce qu'elle
est très politique
dans les deux chambres
et la réforme ferroviaire tout d'abord
les communistes et l'UMP ont voté contre
c'était au Sénat le texte Vista
stabilisé la dette de la SNCF et
préparer l'entreprise à la concurrence
Roger carottis cette réforme valait-elle
vraiment 14 jours de grève
non elle valait pas 14 jours de grève
d'abord parce que le statut des
cheminots n'a absolument pas concerné
parce qu'en plus le gouvernement a
refusé dans la pratique toute ouverture
à la concurrence j'ai déposé avec mes
amis un certain nombre de rendements et
on a débattu beaucoup sur l'ouverture à
la concurrence il y a quasi rien parce
que le ministre peut-être a juste titre
dit mais c'était prévu par la Commission
européenne en 2019 ces reporté à 2022
donc comme c'est dans 8 ans 9 ans au
diable avarice
pourquoi il y a rien dans ce texte qu'il
menace ni le statut des cheminots ni
l'ouverture à la concurrence ni même la
régionalisation où on nous a donné trois
miettes mais et puis en revanche rien
n'est fait pour aiguillir la dette la
dette elle est intégrée à SNCF réseau 44
milliards merci pour le temps d'en
parler on parle d'un autre dossier qui a
causé aussi des manifs et des grèves le
conflit entre les taxis et les VTC la
loi a été adoptée ce jeudi à l'Assemblée
les tax obtenu gain de cause sur la
géolocalisation des véhicules elle sera
donnée au taxi à enlever au VTC mais la
profession des taxis devra être réformés
une question simple vous êtes plutôt VTC
ou taxi Roger caoutchi
d'abord parce que pardon de vous dire en
fonction comme ça surtout à Paris mais
je trouve que dans les deux cas il faut
faire évoluer les choses
déloyale les taxis le disent c'est une
concurrence déloyale sur certaines
obligations et certaines charges qui
pèsent sur les taxis qui ne pèsent pas
sur les VTC donc c'est vrai que si on
voulait dire on ouvre la concurrence
pour de bon il faudrait que les deux
corporations et les mêmes charges les
mêmes contributions ça on y est pas
encore bon c'est pas le cas donc c'est
un peu compliqué ceci étant je pense que
par exemple il faudra bien un jour
accepter d'ouvrir un peu plus de
licences de taxi sur l'Île-de-France
c'est c'est pas possible de continuer
comme ça vous êtes à Londres vous avez
un taxi enlevant la main vous êtes à
Paris essayez un soir ou essayer alors
je parle pas la circulation automobile à
Paris qui est catastrophique du fait de
la mairie mais bon au-delà de ça c'est
plus vivable quoi des rapports chaque
Attali qui avait remis ça à Nicolas
Sarkozy rapport qui avait été remis à
François Hollande et à chaque fois et ça
bouge pas difficile mais parce que en
même temps on veut pas mais il faut
faire une table ronde pour dire encore
une non mais une table ronde rapide il
faut se dire en un mois on dit au VTC ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour avoir les
mêmes charges les mêmes contrôles les
mêmes réglementations que les taxis et
on ouvre et on tranche on va terminer la
semaine avec un peu de politique fiction
ça remonte à quelques temps c'était il y
a 16 ans c'était une fiction américaine
qui nous racontait l'envers du décor de
la communication politique à
l'américaine un film avec Dustin Hoffman
et Robert De Niro et bien cet été on
vous permet sur les chaînes
parlementaires de revoir ce film Des
hommes d'influence extrait Simon
barbarie aujourd'hui
photos du président et de la Jeannette a
été prise durant la visite de la Maison
Blanche à 15 jours d'une élection
présidentielle un scandale éclabousse le
candidat sortant comment rester dans la
course après une telle affaire faire
diversion qu'est-ce qui pourrait
détourner l'opinion publique rien rien
du tout mais rien mais jamais rien vous
pensez que il faudrait au moins une
guerre
une guerre oui inventé de toutes pièces
contre un obscur pays des Balkans rien
de mieux pour fédérer les électeurs
c'est le postulation cynique du film
culte de Barry lewinson des hommes
d'influence à revoir sur Public Sénat
cet été précurseur à sa sortie il y a 16
ans le réalisateur je t'ai déjà les
bases de la communication de crise pour
redorer l'image du pouvoir rien de tel
que le pouvoir des images et pour la
guerre du Golfe qu'est-ce qu'on vous a
montré une toute petite bombe explosant
dans une cheminée la réalité j'étais sur
place quand on a tourné cette scène ça
s'est tourné en studio à fosse en
Virginie il s'agissait d'une maquette
d'immeubles vous plaisantez vous pouvez
en être sûr poussez à l'extrême cette
satire politique nous rappelle le rôle
prépondérant des conseillers en
communication dans les sphères du
pouvoir incarné par deux monstres sacrés
du cinéma Robert De Niro et Dustin
Hoffman ces hommes d'influence
interpellent par son histoire totalement
irréelle qui au fil du temps et au
rythme des scandales politiques de ces
dernières années a pris des accents de
plus en plus crédible à la condition
bien sûr de suivre le fameux précepte
plus c'est gros et mieux ça passe il
nous faut un thème une chanson des
images qui sont marquantes oui un
spectacle un spectacle c'était il y a
sans rien n'a changé et bien au
contraire peut-être malheureusement il y
a plus besoin d'inventer il y en a
partout donc vous avez peut-être besoin
en ce moment d'une stratégie pour
détourner l'attention peut-être que il
faudrait donner un peu moins de pouvoir
communiquant et un peu plus au vrai
politique ils ont pris le pouvoir les
politiques les vrais en plus le sens des
gens les communicants en plus le sens de
l'image mais il faut arrêter de faire en
sorte que l'image domine sur la réalité
plus qu'un atout ces hommes de Londres
aux sociétés de communication qui
prennent le pouvoir on peut s'en servir
à une campagne électorale mais ceux
doivent être des gens qui
comprennent ce que veut le politique et
pas lui impose la manière de réfléchir
encore plus les citoyens de la politique
finalement
c'est peut-être ma conception oui en
tout cas ce film
à 22h sur Public Sénat merci beaucoup
Roger on se retrouve l'année prochaine
en tout cas la rentrée de du mois de
septembre nouveau décor nouveau plateau
mais nous on sera là bonne semaine à
tous bon été bon été à tous